you realize that this world is is
becoming more and more tech
focused and cities have two options they
can either embrace that reality
or they can ignore it to their to their
apparel to the peril of their residence
all right i'm dave rubin we are on
location
in miami with miami mayor francis suarez
mr mayor first off the shirt
matches the shoes matches the socks you
are living
in the synthwave future that was
promised to us in the 80s huh
that's right that's right this is miami
for you know it's miami style
this is absolutely definitely miami
style i mean i guess the best way to
start this off is that
this place is just blowing up you you
got to be kind of feeling good about
life and the world and what you're doing
yeah the easiest question ever been
asked to you before it's the most common
that's yeah
yeah no it really is i think a
generational opportunity a generational
moment
miami was always a great place i mean
pre this sort of tech boom
uh we were growing significantly we're
not a very
you know we're not a well-kept secret
but i think what is happening now
is order of magnitudes different right
you're now
creating a kind of ecosystem and economy
that's really going to propel our city
into the future the world is changing
it's changing at a
at a pace of disruption that we've never
seen before and we're talking about this
a little bit off camera you know
cities just don't get it oftentimes they
don't understand
that uh things are changing and they're
changing permanently and they have to
adapt
quickly when did you get it i mean did
you know about this sort of shift before
you were elected in 2017 or did this
just happen
so i was actually elected in 2009 to the
council
as a councilman and for about 10 years
we were trying to create this
technological ecosystem i
you know almost young i'm a young
elected official for a major city i'm 43
i was 32 at the time and i realized that
i was a first generation with the with
the smartphone i was the first
generation
uh with laptops uh cell phones and and
and you realize that
our world is more and more engulfed
by technological tools i now have a
seven-year-old and a three-year-old
and my three-year-old just the other
night was telling me dad let's take a
selfie
with her with her with her you know we
call it in spanish with her
with her pacifier you know she's taking
a selfie with me so three years old
so you realize camera's in pacifiers
that's uh and it's on its way
it's coming it's common yeah but you
know it you know you realize that
this world is is becoming more and more
tech focused
and cities have two options they can
either embrace that reality
or they can ignore it to their to their
apparel to the peril of their residence
were you worried at all that the people
were gonna come from san francisco and
bring all of the bad policies and ideas
that
basically wrecked silicon valley and
wrecked san francisco i hear the worry a
lot
i actually don't worry and i'll tell you
why you know my
family unfortunately was exiled from a
communist country in cuba
and i don't see people you know getting
on rafts and trying to go back to cuba
you know what i mean it's just not the
people that come here to miami
are traumatized they're traumatized by
governments that don't work by policies
that don't work
and frankly you know the decision to
leave a particular city is a very
difficult decision
particularly when you have a family and
to uproot your family and say i'm going
somewhere else that is not easy
um and so for me i find it very hard to
believe that anybody's going to make
that very difficult decision
basically trauma-based right to come to
a new city and then create the same
policies that created the conditions for
them to want to leave
in the first place what kind of chaos
has it caused in the last year being
here i mean
real estate prices are bananas rents are
going crazy these are all
good set of problems but it must be a
lot for you to just have to manage
you know what's interesting uh the real
estate prices are bananas in homes that
are on the water
like this home you know what i mean but
uh we're competitively speaking
incredibly affordable
so for example in downtown miami the
urban core
uh you can get a one bedroom apartment
in an unsubsidized like not affordable
housing or anything like that
uh building brand new fourteen hundred
fifty dollars
in manhattan it's thirty seven hundred
dollars in san francisco it's 3 700
so you're talking about a three to one
differential that hasn't changed
uh from one day to the next and so and
then you know we're building a ton of
affordable housing uh we have the
ability to build supply which cities
like
san francisco the bay area oftentimes
and new york can't do because new york
is sort of overbuilt and san francisco
has restricted their
ability to build so uh so we have the
ability to remain competitive
for decades into the future which i
think is a huge competitive advantage
for our city
so i think when most people think of
conservatives they think of
some kind of old white guy sitting in a
smoking room
and you know flipping through the wall
street journal or something like that
you're a conservative it seems to me
that you're sort of what the future of
conservatism is
what does that actually mean to you like
what are your kind of guiding principles
you know i grew up
uh i was born in 1977 so i grew up sort
of in the 80s 76 you're
you're a young buck there you go my dad
was mayor in 1985
of miami and i grew up sort of in the
reagan years so for me
instead of being a reagan republican was
someone that was strong on national
defense
um you know for me i believe in having a
balanced budget even though that's
something that our federal government
has not been able to do for a long time
are you guys balanced here we are we
actually have a surplus we have a 150
million
surplus in the city of miami the second
highest bond rating we've ever had in
the highest we've ever had in the
history
under my leadership so that's a double a
plus so
you know i believe in fiscal
responsibility for governments i think
government should live within their
means
uh i think that uh you know government
should be there to facilitate not
obstruct
and oftentimes uh they are
obstructionist uh
you know i but as a conservative i also
and as a young person and someone who
sees
even young conservatives uh and and and
young liberals come up
concerned about the environment so i
think that's something that you know we
have to have a
better conversation on immigration is
another issue that you know we're a city
of immigrants
uh we're a country of immigrants you
know and that's a a you know another
issue i think we need to have a
healthier conversation
i'm in the one that we're having right
now and in the sort of national
landscape
yeah where does uh the bitcoin stuff fit
in this new future conservative
mecca that we've got going well i think
just did the big conference
yeah we just did the biggest the largest
bitcoin conference in in the world
we also had ftx which is a large a
crypto trading platform out of hong kong
uh named the uh the arena where the
miami heat plate 200 million dollar
naming deal we had blockchain.com
headquarter in the city of miami 300
jobs
and etoro which is don't forget
locals.com moved here and locals.com as
well and etoro as well so
i mean we've had a ton of of of crypto
uh companies moving over here in
blockchain and bitcoin companies moving
over here because
we believe we were sort of the david in
this david and goliath story right yeah
but we believe that uh to be uh
sort of to have that transformational
moment we had to step outside of the
conventional box
and i thought that bitcoin and crypto
was our way of doing that
uh you know we're the first city in the
world uh sort of the first state in the
united states second city in the world
to put to satoshi's white paper on our
website
uh you know we're the first city in the
world to begin the process of allowing
our employees to get paid in bitcoin
uh of allowing uh do you get do you get
all of it or is it just like you have
good people around you like because some
of the tech
stuff the high-end high-level tech stuff
is a lot no i get it i get it i get it
because i
sort of finance background my dad was an
engineer
uh is an engineer my grandfather was an
engineer as well
so i get the mathematics behind it i get
the principle behind that i was actually
part of the florida blockchain
foundation when it began
and i'm actually actually part of the
florida blockchain task force named by
the cfo of florida
uh to promulgate uh state regulations
and laws
to hope hopefully to continue to bring
crypto to miami so it's
into florida do you have other mayors in
either in florida or in the rest of the
country that are kind of pissed
they're kind of jealous like this guy's
making it happen and we're not either
because we're handicapped by our own
state governments or whatever it might
be you know the ones that probably would
be pissed are not calling you know
i think i think they feel like they're
yeah i can't speak for them they may
feel like they're boxing they may
believe
some of the policies that their their
cities are promulgating that i think are
are not good for their cities but i can
tell you i've gotten a ton of mayors
that call me
from across the country uh and and
chambers of commerce from across the
country that call me and say hey how do
we replicate what you're doing down
there
and for us it's you know there are some
things that are hard to replicate
you know miami's kind of hard to
replicate but there are other things
that i think are very basic
you know for us we have basically our
formula for success is three things
keep taxes as low as humanly possible uh
while other cities defund police we're
investing in our police and we have the
highest
a number of police officers ever so
public safety is incredibly important to
us it's something that we sell
being one of the safest big cities in
america and the third thing is we focus
on quality of life
we know the fundamental truth that
nobody can live yesterday again
so the most important decision that we
all make in our lives is where we are
this very moment where we're going to be
tomorrow
we're going to be the day after and if
you create the kind of city that really
respects that decision
uh for example we have 555 homeless in
the city of miami we want to get to
functional zero which means we want to
be one of the first big cities in
america not to have
any homeless i mean i've been here for
five days i have not seen one homeless
person
i come from la it's very very different
it's very different and i think uh you
know we've done a variety of things over
a number of years to get to that point
um and we want to get to zero so like
what for for example what's one thing
you've done on the homeless
that i can bring back with me to
california we have something called the
homeless trust yeah
we we spend about 50 million dollars a
year it's a it's a food and beverage tax
that's
basically a tourist tax that's not paid
for by our residents but it generates
money and we use that money to to build
facilities
uh to treat homeless in a comprehensive
way there obviously a lot of them have
mental health and drug addiction issues
and vocational training so that they can
leave
you know a shelter with the ability to
make a living and reintegrate into
society so they get mental health
counseling
they get drug addiction counseling and
they also get vocational training
when you see the mayors of say la san
francisco seattle portland
all the progressive mayors that are just
raising taxes and then you see the
reverse of all of the policies that
you've got working here
do you ever think maybe i could just
call these guys and explain like basic
economics to them or something like
like i just never can understand the
disconnect between
the things that they say and then the
results that end up happening well i get
to a lot of them are my friends
um and and i'm gonna be if i re-elected
in november which hopefully will be a
non-event god willing
you got elected with 86 percent and uh
i mean what are we going to do we do 90
days what are you saying listen you got
to go up man
that's it i'll tell you a funny story
about that later but uh i think
you know if we're elected i'm going to
be the president of the us conference of
mayors so one of the cool things is
uh my my colleagues those mayors have
have
chosen me to be the president of all the
mayors in the united states and i think
it's a really wonderful opportunity to
take this formula that has been
successful in miami and export it to
urban america
i think there's some things that we can
do on gun violence there's some things
you can do on homelessness
and frankly you know i'm willing to talk
to anybody any mayor and give them
advice
uh you know but sometimes i think it's
hard because it's either
what they believe which is sort of
antithetical to what i think is a growth
policy
or what the residents believe which
oftentimes make it
hard because they're sort of boxed in
right where does desantis
fit into all this it seems like from
again from me 3000 miles away
that's the best governor in the country
right now yeah so he's you know i think
he
he did some things that were very um
sort of counter narrative right
and opened the state up a lot earlier
than a lot of people thought what
would have been a good idea and it
turned out to be great for the city
certainly great for the state
and he's gotten a ton of kudos on that
and i think you know i i
i'm pretty sure that if he's re-elected
in 2022 which i think is also
you know he's got a very good shot of
that uh 2024 i wouldn't be surprised if
he puts his name in the ring right
so a little glimmer in the eye i think
you might know something there oh you
know what what is that where does that
put you then
you know look i i've um you know again i
have to get reelected and
obviously i have a year and a half as
hopefully present year's conference of
mayors but
you know i've talked about this in in
the past there's only a few things that
i'd be interested in doing beyond being
mayor which has been an amazing thing
being governor in the state of florida
in 2026 or something that i would be
i would certainly consider does it ever
seem odd to you that you're governor of
all things like somebody who gets it
like you get business and all of those
things
i know there's a lot of good people
usually kind of right leaning who just
don't want to go into government because
they don't believe that government
is everything so then they just don't do
it and then we get worse and worse
politicians well that's part of the
problem government isn't everything it
shouldn't be everything i think part of
the issue we have in our society is
people think that government needs to
solve all our problems
it's not the way it works government is
was supposed to be created for a limited
amount of reasons
uh the things that we're good at our
core competencies and then you know when
you have good leaders that lead in
government
they can work with the private sector
with the philanthropic sectors to deal
with
big problems uh like homelessness and
others but i think uh you know there's
this misperception that you just keep
growing the size of government
um and that it can somehow solve a bunch
of problems that government has been
historically unable to do it put
band-aids on problems it's it's created
right like exactly that's pretty much it
exactly what's going to make the
problems worse or make them worse
what's been sort of unexpected as this
all has blown up here
on i guess either on good or bad like
just generally like so much at once
yeah you know for me if you would have
told me on december 3rd right that
the next day i was going to put out a
tweet uh that was going to be
they call it the tweet heard around the
world yeah how can i help tweet in terms
of making
miami silicon valley and that that was
going to get 2.7 million
impressions or honestly i don't think i
knew of you until then and that day
suddenly everyone i knew in the tech
world was like that's the guy that's the
city let's go and then it's just been
it's been crazy and ever since then i
mean i i found what i call
in twitter uh a portal positivity yeah
you know what i mean and i tweeted 800
more times in the month of december
uh which got 27 million generally that's
not a good thing but
in your case it's okay yeah and it you
know and it's going to sound
really hokey-pokey what i'm gonna tell
you but in many ways i found my voice
you know i mean it kind of sounds you
know uh book clubish you know but i i
really did i
i was able to really express myself be
myself without
the the usual concerns and worries that
hey am i going to make a mistake am i
going to say something wrong
you know usually if you look at elected
officials in social media it's very
antiseptic
it's like they won and they cut a ribbon
or they did this you know they don't
have a personality they can't really
express themselves because they're
afraid they're afraid of making a
mistake or saying the wrong thing
and at some point i just said you know
what i'm going to go all in
let's see how this goes yeah you know
and it's been great it's it's been a lot
of fun
i i've you know it's part of what
allowed me to get into the crypto space
as well at the level that i did
because i was i was really getting great
feedback yeah and i said you know what i
gotta do more
were you kind of shocked so you put that
tweet out and then it was basically
everyone that i know in the tech world
was just like that's it were you just
shocked that they immediately were like
what can i do and then and then you
basically just set up meetings with
people right
i was shocked but it was also a
tremendous
uh learning experience right in the
sense that i realized
what this world was all about now this
world is is
highly highly disruptive i mean i mean i
got to say this i don't even know what
camera looking to
this world is highly somewhere somewhere
over there here this world is highly
highly disruptive
to the point where uh the paradigm can
shift on you in
in a second yeah and i think that's what
some of these cities are not completely
understanding
you know and and i think that as you see
what i call this confluence of capital
coming from new york
silicon valley and miami's geo position
right
close to south america and central
america close to the middle
east israel and and uh and europe
we're sort of in the middle of all that
we're the place that can really be that
global mega
city that can be what i call the capital
of capital
the place where if you want to build a
business or start a business you've got
to be living in miami
low taxes is that i mean is that does it
all sort of boil down to that at the
beginning
that's a part of the equation but it's
not all of the equation i mean i think
for us it was low taxes
it's incredible weather it's incredible
amenities from a city perspective now
the restaurants
you know everything is sort of coming
together and i think
and this is going to sound again sort of
crazy but it's it's being welcoming
right i i can't tell you more people
have told me look i i i would live in
i would stay living in one of these
cities i'm still paying a lot of taxes
i'm not getting the services i'm not
getting a return on my investment i'm
not getting any stuff but at the top
you're just talking right to me now but
on top of everything else
yeah i'm made to feel like i'm not a
good person
right like the government officials f
elon musk the
let's criticize mark zuckerberg for
giving 75 million dollars to a hospital
for them wanting to name it after him
let's
let's push amazon out of our city i mean
that just
doesn't make any sense and what we've
been doing is the opposite we're like
okay
you know we're come you know keep coming
and we're creating thousands of
high-paying jobs in our community
that are going to have a
tri-generational impact tri-generation
impact it impacts the person who has a
job in their spouse
it impacts their children and their
educational opportunities and it's going
to impact their children's children
how do you make sure that the people
that are the natives here in the midst
of this as some prices rise and things
like that don't get
pushed out of communities that they're
in and that sort of thing yeah you know
it's a hard challenge you know because
uh and i was actually doing an interview
recently where where uh with one of our
local papers and and i said look it's
hard because
you know the the the first thing is
people uh sort of complain that
there's a lot of income inequality in
cities which is true you know it's a
problem in urban america
and then you start bringing high-paying
jobs and they say well you're going to
push out
so it's like well what do you want you
want high-paying jobs or do you want or
or so how do we deal with income
inequality if we don't bring high-paying
jobs and i think
i think that what ties those two things
is you got to create an educational
framework
from you know young children to
university students
to young adults who are left out of the
tech ecosystem
to even the elderly to create a
framework where they can be integrated
into this economy and so we do it uh
with child savings accounts to teach
financial literacy
every single child in kindergarten the
city of miami gets a child savings
account that we fund
we do it through a coding program we
just raised through the how can i help
campaign
seventy thousand dollars for a coding
program in the inner city for robotics
and coding
we're helping facilitate a tremendous
amount of philanthropy to universities
and even working with some major
universities marquee universities to try
to get
partnerships uh you know maybe bridge
that reputational gap that we may have
you know we're doing a tremendous amount
of stuff on upscaling uh either through
vocational training
uh or through companies like winco that
was bought by brain station
and then for the elderly we're working
with apps like papa
uh to make sure that it it's you know
that's relevant to them
this tech boom yeah it's you mentioned
the elderly i was going to ask you
like i think a lot of people think of
florida but miami specifically i tweeted
a golden girls clip at you yesterday
they think oh but this is this is yeah
they're not going to do the golden girls
theme song
that's not going to be the official
theme song of miami all right i'll keep
working on you on that one but
uh that people think of florida as like
oh that's where old people go to retire
was our reputation yeah
our reputation was we're a sun and fun
place or retirement place
and i think you know what i try to do
with how can i help tweed and beyond
was was you know i don't know if you've
ever seen the cruise ship's turn
okay when it when it when it like
literally literally when it turns on a
cruise ship comes into port it comes in
this way and they just got to turn it
to go outward it actually takes forever
right because you're gonna it's a huge
massive thing it's like a city that
you're turning i literally got every
single tugboat
in miami and turned what was the
reputation of miami which is like a
cruise ship turning it as fast as
possible
so we could create two new industries
and technology and finance that are high
paying
and they're going to propel us into the
future and make us a city of the future
all right two more things for you and
then and then i'm gonna join you in just
a moment we're gonna flip the script
here
i love it um so first off yeah so first
off i'm i'm moving my company locals
down here
we're we're hiring right now we're
hiring right now
what when yeah what can we do to get
word out there i mean
what kind of resources are there as
companies move down well first of all
what we're doing right now is
the number one thing we can do which is
you know you have to i've learned after
12 years this is why these podcasts
are so uh have gotten so much uh you
know
play right is is because we're in the
storytelling business
right i'm in the storytelling because i
realized after 12 years of being in
politics like i am now a storyteller
right and the story is the narrative of
what miami is and what miami is going to
be
and so just this podcast and and the one
that we're going to do on the
conferencing tech talk
continue to tell that story to a point
where people may have doubted it at the
beginning you know this is this is just
going to be a covet thing or this is
just gonna be a you know in the summer
everybody will leave you know
but when you keep telling the story over
and over again you pile on success
after success after success the
perception becomes a reality you marry
perception with reality so
that's that's really important i think
one of the things that we want them to
know is
we're setting up funds we have a fund
already through the downtown development
authority that gives
as opposed to kicking out a company we
give companies fifty thousand dollars
a year for three years that located in
downtown miami
we're hopefully creating a fund called a
venture miami
uh which will be hopefully an early
stage seed fund
which we're going to have somewhere
between two and five million dollars a
year over the next two years to help
early stage companies grow which often
times you know they're the ones that
have the hardest time you know with the
mom and pop
and so that that so we're trying to do
everything we can to accelerate this
this this ecosystem growth then my final
question for you is
if i make the move if i just can't take
callie anymore i make the move myself
can you hook me up with a house like
this when you make the move
uh we will do everything that we can we
like to have yeah
all right i'll take it i'll take that
red carpet service we call it you know
concierge service so yeah
so that's pretty much the limit of what
a mayor can say well i can't give you
the house but i can put you in touch
with people who may want to sell you a
house like this
mayor suarez thank you so much awesome
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell